alors on y est vous avez vidéo vous avez
du débat on va faire une interview un
penda et on est qu'est ce que vous
préférez en vous ma paresse qu'est-ce
que vous haïssez en vous ma vérité votre
chanson préférée une chanson de bruce
qui s'appelle innocente chanoine c'est
beau ça c'est une de mes préférées
vraiment un challenge comme la chanson
que vous aimez le mois j'avoue que
j'aime le moins c'est la chanson de lara
ah ouais
oui c'est le père de jean rède 1
c'est guimauve c'est ça ouais juste pas
et aussi nous y aura tenu à vous l'aimez
pas ça me ramène à dire aux indiens qui
vomissent 4
verdict le plus grand moment de votre
vie à grand moment de ma vie c'est
d'avoir gagné un concours de cuisine
avec guy savoy et puis 1 et c'était un
concours pro am et professionnels
amateurs donc je précise et on a gagné
et on a fait un canard et aux deux fois
le thème imposé était un canard et moi
j'étais mûr et le canard etc alors ça
ressemble un peu aux normes ifrs et non
canard j'ai été obligé de répéter dix
fois j'ai fini canard dans la cuisine ça
non je ferai ça le plus pur moment de
votre vie le pire moment pas cessé
d'avoir raté un concert parce que
j'entendais rien et je les rater voilà
un mais je sais fatigué de haut c'était
à nice et je me souviens avec michel
leeb
oui ça pour ça non michel leeb que je la
kiffe tellement reconnaissante qui a vu
que même à l'époque
je m'épanouis c'est un peu et qui a
repris jusqu'au moment où moi j'ai pu
reprendre ses biens et voilà donc ça
tirait un des plus mauvais souvenir pas
pour me jal est bien sûr je remercierai
est toujours à genoux enfin je ne m'en
fais pas nouveau qu'est ce que vous
préférez dans la vie prend la rigolade
la rigolade
l'urgence est ce que je préfère c'est
aussi cette espèce de douleur qui porte
et qui vous qui vous portent jusqu'à la
rigolade parce qu'on a tellement marre
d'un mal qu'on dit allez sa fille ça
suffit maintenant alors à rigoler un peu
quand même et on a du mal on a du mal et
on est ce qui vous fait le plus chez
dans la vie à me lever tôt me lever très
tôt c'est un votre plus belle histoire
d'amour c'est là qu'elle est
ces scènes avec un un homme qu'on admire
parce que dans l'amour il ya tellement
d'admiration
on peut pas aimer quelqu'un sans
l'admirer salué sans se dire tiens non
merveilleux j'aurais voulu faire comme
lui et tout ça donc donc dans l'amour il
ya énormément d'admiration et moi bon
c'est vrai que michel maes a été un
nouveau grand amour de la vie mais c'est
j'en ai eu d'autres 1 et j'en ai un
autre à demain maintenant là bas voilà
est la plus moche histoire d'amour voyez
pas non franchement je n'ai pas non non
j'en ai pas d'ailleurs ça se dit pas les
plus moches et plus moche c'est
oubliable jetables c'est comme un vieux
kleenex
on les jette on veut pas les les garder
en soi bas à votre avis véronique qu'est
ce que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
rien à non je vous ont rien g sauf
peut-être certains de mes regards a
quand même mais je crois qu'il s'inscrit
qui est 2 et de moins sexy disposer de
moins sexy en asie la même chose puisque
rien et sexy donc moins sexy peu ce qui
fait ça va c'est vrai ici comme un
ornithorynque
ehrlich chansons l'album qui appelle
longues distances elle s'appelle saint
homme
je t'aime
là